Một em bẻ được xin chút được ở tôn thái bà miệm bị đủ trọn giờ đẹp bị C-ho hấp,
xí tình hoàn khu tế qua khó.
Thế đó, một chẻ xin 2 ngày tuổi được mổ lấy thái ở tôn bà miệm bị thế ước cầu của ra đình đủ trọn ngày giờ đẹp.
Ngay sau sinh, chẻ có biểu hị xí hồ hấp, phải thử UC và chuyên việc hình cấp.
Huy đến chút tâm xe sinh, chẻ đã trong tình trạm tím tái, xí tình hoàn nghiên trọng và được trình đoán tăng áp lực động mệt của nạc.
Mặc dù được hồi sức tích cực, sử dụng các kỹ thật cao nhìn chè vẫn không đáp ứng với các biệt pháp được gì và không qua khó.
Xin thường là phục pháp tốt nhất, sinh lấy nhất cho mẹ và mẹ, mổ lấy thái chỉ nên thực hiện khi có gì để ki qua.
Tuy nhiên, hẹn ai nhiều ra đình vẫn trọn xin 1 chút động khi mẹ chứ có giấu hiệu chuyên giả để trọn ngày giờ đẹp với hi vọng con mình xin ra sẽ có tương lai mái mắn, tự lời.
Du vời, lựa trọn này lại tìm ở New Week, có thể anh vừa viên trọn đến xúc hỏa thẩm xí là tính mạng của cả mẹ và chẻ xin.
Bây giờ đình mong muốn gọi người giờ đẹp.
Theo bào cao tụng két cũng tắt trong xóc xúc hỏa bà mẹ chè em của bộ ít tế năm 2018,
tỷ lệ sinh 1 chứng gần 8,5 tổ xúc cà xin, có một số bình bị lên đến năm 2019.
Các hơn nhiều lần xóc với mức mùi đến vệ lắm phần chăm mà tổ chức ít tế thề dưới phyng cáo đề bảo vệ xúc hỏa của mẹ và chẻ xe xin.
Nhằm hạn chế các biệt chứng vi nhiên có thể xe ra.
Tỷ lệ sinh 1 tăng giòn nhiều muên nhân trong đó phục biến là việc các dành chủ động lựa trọn ngày, giờ xin.
Bên kẹn đó, những ca chuyển ra có quyết cơ cao thường được bắt sĩ chỉ định mù để đảm bảo ăn toàn cho mẹ và mẹ.
Các chuyên ra ít tế cạnh báo, sinh 1 tiêm ở nhiều dưới gió hơn sau với sinh thường,
gây lòng ngày vì xúc hỏa lâu dài cho cảm mẹ và mẹ.